[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parle sport l'émission ne surtout pas
manqué si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local au programme aujourd'hui
comme toujours des analystes techniques
des décryptages et surtout une dose de
bonne humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau présentation en musique de cette
magnifique dream team on commence à ma
droite musique il est de retour parmi
nous il est plus affûté que jamais il
est prêt à défendre ses idées il est
notre spécialiste cyclisme sur piste
cyclisme sur route voile roller et même
Mölkky le capitaine vient du Jarrier le
pistard est avec nous pendant une heure
Michael oui Molkky c'est le sport favori
que mes enfants pendant l'été que pour
pratiquer
du coup pour cette émission ouais j'ai
perdu un peu de poids la dernièrement et
il me reste encore un peu à perdre
n'hésitez pas à nous donner votre cours
de croissance voilà n'hésitez pas en
tout cas on continue notre tour de table
à gauche musique sa musique et iconique
il est journaliste chez tv78 il est
expert du sport et Vinois et du football
italien il est notre escalope milanaise
il est aussi fondant qu'une panna cotta
notre italienne lover notre Vésuve
Grégory canalet est avec nous pendant
une heure bonjour Michael bonjour Yann
bonjour à tous je suis 100 mots à chaque
fois sur vos présentations qui sont
juste exceptionnelles escalope milanaise
je l'avais pas vu venir celle-là
effectivement je travaille beaucoup en
amour bon et en tout cas oui grand
plaisir d'être avec la team un nettoyage
lover tu prends un peu de repos en ce
moment avec une coupe du monde bien sûr
de football sans l'Italie on prend un
peu de repos et on laisse de gagner les
autres on entend pas de la Coupe du
Monde du coup oui il faut laisser gagner
les autres de temps en temps 4 étoiles
on le rappelle pour l'Italie et il
envolé aussi dans quelques instants
on termine de l'autre côté musique c'est
un mélange entre George Clooney et
Russell Crow il est toujours aussi
élégant et toujours aussi taquin il
adore le rugby et les 3e mi-temps
toujours avec modération notre
gladiateur pire chevalière responsable
communication Rugby Club de Versailles
est avec nous pendant une heure et ben
ça Perly popette il y a eu quand même
des efforts de rédaction là quand même
sur les présentations et les lancements
depuis la dernière émission voilà je
fais ça
tout simplement c'est notable c'est noté
et vraiment ça mais ça met en joie
former bonheur à tous et ça se passe
comment Rugby Club de Versailles
justement on est pas mal on est pas mal
les petits poucets les petits pouces et
montants se font une place en Fédérale 2
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal au milieu
entre nous avec un avec des des
victoires à l'extérieur après des matchs
un peu moins bien gérer à domicile un
petit accident et puis le reste on a mis
les poursuivants directs dans la course
au maintien un petit peu à distance à 10
points au moins et puis on en est on est
là sur une une dernière très belle
performance au reux qui est l'équipe qui
est numéro 2 sur cette pôle là des gros
épouvantails de cette poule là et on a
failli la réserve à gagner et la
première a perdu d'un point donc ramène
le bonus défensif ce qui était pas gagné
et a failli même l'emporter donc il y a
du soleil dans la cité du roi soleil
exactement il y a une belle dynamique
une belle dynamique très bien ça oui de
partout alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission on va prendre la
direction du vélo de Drôme national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des lumières
de la musique une piste qui s'illumine
la troisième étape de Lucie trek
Champions League était organisé fin
novembre dans la structure un événement
programmé pour la première fois au vélo
de route nationale de 50 ans en ligne et
qui a réuni les meilleures pisteurs
mondiaux avec un objectif en tête pour
les organisateurs casser les codes on
écoute Bruce Goldstein responsable
market au Vélodrome l'ADN de l'ucel
tracks Champions League c'est vraiment
de fabriquer de l'entertainment autour
du cyclisme sur fixe donc des animations
à travers de la nouvelle technologie on
va conserver exclusivement les formats
les plus impressionnants en matière de
sport toujours autour du cyclisme sur
piste et c'est vraiment voilà pour se
démarquer de ce qui peut se faire
d'habitude et de continuer à développer
cette pratique d'attirer encore plus de
monde des familles comme ce qui se fait
en Angleterre à Berlin d'attirer tout ce
monde là en France et plus
particulièrement à 50 ans en Yvelines
au total plus de 3000 spectateurs sont
venus voir ce spectacle ce samedi 26
novembre la question sur cette
thématique est-ce que c'est un bon bilan
pour cette UCI Champions League au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
oui ou non partager pour vous pire
chevalier je sais pas trop quoi
avec le calendrier qu'on a sur 50 ans en
Yvelines eu cette année avec les
championnats du monde qui ont eu lieu au
mois d'octobre mi-octobre
voilà 16 octobre c'est vrai que une
Champions League avec un plateau un peu
moins un peu moins intéressant même si
on a tous les tous les femmes beaucoup
des meilleurs mais c'est moins dangereux
peut-être voilà simplement moins
d'enjeux c'est vrai que c'est quand même
difficile de vivre dans un créneau aussi
aussi rapproché donc pour moi 3000 3000
personnes sur le vélo drone 3000
personnes présentes sur le vélo de route
je trouve ça vraiment très très bien
et ça n'empêche que ça permet aussi d'en
parler de voir que le spectacle est de
qualité et
là quand on vient dans un vélo de route
on passe un bon moment et je pense que
c'est de bonne augure pour pour les
prochaines années parce que la dernière
ça devait avoir lieu et ça n'a pas pu
avoir lieu à cause du
vaccinodrome d'enlever l'eau de Rome
donc ça veut dire qu'ils vont encore
venir l'année prochaine je crois que il
y avait une concession de trois ans pour
minimum de de présence sur sur 50 ans
Libye donc c'est plutôt c'est plutôt de
bonne augure pour pour la suite et
longue vie à cette épreuve parce que ah
oui là c'est vrai que l'actualité sur le
vélo de Saint-Quentin et elle est
florissante mais il peut y avoir des
années où il y a il y aurait rien
d'autre que la Champions League et bah
dans ces cas-là on serait bien content
de bien content de l'avoir ce type de
manche une fois par saison à la maison
c'est quand même c'est quand même bien
sympa Grégory qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous étiez sur place j'étais sur
place alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
tout n'était pas gagné au départ il y a
très bien dit on sortait de championnats
du monde au Vélodrome qui avait très
bien fonctionné qui avait eu du mal à se
remplir au début mais qui finalement sur
le week-end avait fait avait fait le
plein et au niveau des résultats
sportifs on s'était émerveillé de la
performance de Mathilde de gros qui
avait enfin décroché cette médaille d'or
en vitesse c'était pas gagné aussi sur
la date puisque le même jour il y avait
quand même un match qui était en face
c'était le match de l'équipe de France
face au Danemark et moi qui était sur
place aux alentours de 19h ça a du mal à
se remplir sur le début et petit à petit
au gré de la soirée bah les tribunes du
vélo de route nationale se sont pas
remplis à fond mais il y avait quand
même 7 jauge de 3000 spectateurs sur un
vélo Drôme qui fait 5000 places c'était
pas mal mais c'est vrai que moi j'avais
peur face à ce match France Danemark
finalement il était juste avant donc on
va dire que dans le timing ça s'est joué
à très peu de choses donc au final un
une réussite sur le plan de
l'organisation parce que il y a eu ce
Mondial et donc on est un peu dans la
lancée de ce Mondial en vue aussi de ses
Jeux olympiques de Paris qui vont avoir
lieu dans le vélo de route nationale et
une réussite sportive forcément ce que
notre française alors il y avait pas que
Mathilde gros mais il y avait Mathilde
gros encore qui était aligné sur cette
compétition elle a remporté l'étape à 50
ans en Yvelines et ça l'a propulsé la
semaine d'après pour revenir s'imposer
et remporter cette saison de Champions
League donc réussite sportive réussite
du sur le point de vue de l'organisation
et c'est de bonne augure à quelques
années à quelques mois maintenant de
l'organisation de de ces épreuves au
Vélodrome national ces épreuves
olympiques faut quand même rester un peu
en bémol par rapport aux performances ça
reste du sport spectacle voilà faut pas
non plus tout prendre et ça reste voilà
ça reste du du ça vous gêne ou pas
la piste pas toujours été était comme ça
c'est c'est la beauté de la piste
justement de pouvoir
montrer des choses qui vont un peu
sortir de l'ordinaire et de sortir du du
des du schéma
du Vélodrome avec la piste qui
s'illumine ça c'est pas possible de
faire sur un championnat du monde le
cahier des charges sur un champion du
monde il est beaucoup plus stricte ben
voilà là la Champions League permet ce
type de ce type d'animation qui qui
permet de justement d'en mettre un peu
plein le plein les yeux au spectateur il
y a tout ce spectacle à ce tunnel aussi
pour rentrer et aller chercher voilà on
le voit le tunnel qui il y a des petites
led bleu à l'intérieur c'est c'est assez
sympa et même au niveau télévision ça ça
rendait bien l'événement qui était
couvert par nos confrères de Discovery
c'est un spectacle sur la piste un
spectacle aussi télévisuel je pense que
c'était vraiment le maître mot sur sur
cette forêt pire chevalier et vous qui
n'est pas un très très grand de cyclisme
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous d'une
épreuve comme celle-là un peu visuel
avec du son de la lumière des effets mon
propos c'est de dire on a souvent on a
si souvent raillé les fréquentations et
les affluences dont au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin d'abord pour les
compétitions cyclistes et puis on a
ensuite pour les pour les spectacles qui
viennent compléter le calendrier pour ne
pas bouder le plaisir des aficionados et
des et des spectateurs de ce de ce type
de show et je constate plusieurs choses
la première c'est que c'est que c'est un
c'est comme il y a une disait c'est un
sport qui est qui est qui est
spectaculaire et qui là c'est c'est tout
en tout terrain c'est-à-dire en indoor
on peut faire on peut faire des
spectacles et des et des choses de
qualité et là en l'occurrence remplir
deuxièmement 3000 sur une jauge de 5000
c'est là aussi pas si souvent en termes
de proportion dans les enceintes
sportives en France troisième chose je
pense qu'il y a aussi un effet un effet
événement mondiaux qui s'y sont déroulés
et puis la perspective de 2024 avec les
JO ou petit à petit on se rôde on se on
s'entraîne les sportifs comme ceux qui
organisent pour pour accueillir des
compétitions de très haut niveau mondial
international pour les JO et en fait un
petit peu prendre la température de du
spectacle et des spectateurs mais même
pour quelqu'un d'extérieur au cycliste
qui n'est pas le plus grand fan c'est
c'est de toute façon des beaux
événements sportifs et ça pourrait me
donner envie de de passer la tête après
vous je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr
le spectacle
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé au
championnat du monde il y avait des gens
qui étaient assis derrière moi qui ne
connaissaient pas du tout habiter à à La
Celle-Saint-Cloud et qui connaissait pas
le Drôme ils sont venus comme ça et
c'est vrai que bah je pense qu'ils ont
apprécié d'avoir une personne qui
connaît un petit peu le le système pour
leur expliquer justement tous les les
rouages de du cyclisme sur piste c'est
vrai que c'est d'autant plus intéressant
quand on quand on connaît on peut avoir
les explications sur sur tout ce qui se
passe au centre du coup à refaire vous
êtes d'accord autour de cette table bien
sûr une Champions League comme celle-là
ouvrez le Drôme
et les championnats sur orbite Greg la
rappeler en plus ça met les conduit ça
mais par exemple Mathilde gros dans les
conditions idéales pour son palmarès et
pas tant j'espère que ça va perdurer
j'ai perdu très longtemps
et que ça restera une étape restera à 50
ennui parce que faut pas oublier il y en
avait la première au Portugal et puis
les finales se déroulent en Angleterre
quand même voilà à Londres donc oui qui
est quand même un très très beau vélo
Drôme aussi mais c'est vrai que s'ils
peuvent rester sur sur un vélo de route
comme 50 ans en Yvelines ce serait une
très bonne chose il a été fait pour ça a
priori il a été construit aussi pour ce
type d'événements à la base mais oui
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est ça fait
partie des beaux Vélodrome européen et
c'est c'est un des seuls c'est ça qui
fait 8 mètres de large de toute façon en
Europe à part
on n'est pas la Russie dans l'Europe on
est d'accord
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de la Coupe du monde de
football est-ce qu'il y a moins
d'engouement dans les Yvelines nous
parlons également de la Route du Rhum
nous ferons le bilan de nos deux
Illinois Louis Burton et Eric Bellion
mais avant de parler de ces thématiques
on va parler du FC Versailles
[Musique]
après la fin de son aventure au monde
début novembre l'ancien défenseur
central de l'Olympique Lyonnais Christ
est devenu à la mi-novembre le nouvel
entraîneur de Versailles il remplace
Youssef chibi mise à pied par le club
Chris récupère une équipe deuxième du
championnat qui vise sans l'avouer la
montée en fin de saison en Ligue 2 la
question sur cette thématique pour ou
contre son arrivée
à cet entraîneur Chris
lorsque lorsqu'il y a eu les premiers
atermoiements et les premiers les
premiers pour mes épisodes dans le
Dallas du FC Versailles avec Youssef
chibi il y avait des quelques noms du
football qui est qui circulaient là où
je suis Jean-Luc Vasseur
qui sont des qui sont des noms de des
bancs donc de l'entraîneur d'entraîneurs
du football Chris c'est un nom du
football
ancien très bon défenseur le policier de
le policier de Lyon pour l'instant avec
un avec un palmarès d'entraîneur et une
expérience d'entraîneur qui n'est pas à
la hauteur des non constitués au départ
donc c'est là où je suis un petit peu un
petit peu partagé parce que d'un autre
côté étant donné que c'est un nom et
avec une certaine une certaine aura une
certaine notoriété ça met
une fois un coup de projecteur sur le FC
Versailles sur sur cette histoire qui se
construit et c'est finalement là aussi
on le disait assez souvent que c'est
l'appétit qui vient en mangeant avec le
avec le FC Versailles qui découvre qu'il
découvre le National et qui qui
finalement performe il y a eu cette
petite marche ratée au moment du
changement du changement d'entraîneur
qui finalement restait son conséquence
là on est sur une le dernier résultat
une nette victoire contre Sedan donc la
dynamique sportive est là ils sont en
haut au classement
effectivement il la vaut pas encore que
dès la première saison il souhaite
remonter encore à la division supérieure
donc là c'est la Ligue 2 de il y a quand
même un il y a quand même un sacré gap
donc pour pour la poursuite de
l'histoire et du développement sportif
du FC Versailles est-ce que Chris était
le meilleur nom en l'occurrence pour
pour gérer cette étape là éventuellement
jusqu'à la montée en fin de saison de
cette première saison en National
pour la Ligue 2 la mystère pour
l'instant on verra l'histoire le dire il
y a déjà
[Musique]
un grand joueur de Ligue 1 un grand
joueur lyonnais qui a quand même marqué
son époque 17 sélections en sélection
nationale il a été vainqueur de la Copa
América en 2004 il a été champion de
France 4 fois avec Lyon et il était
vainqueur de la Coupe de France en 2012
voilà donc oui un gros palmarès et puis
il était quand même il est aussi une
longévité
2004-2012 donc
on commence à en parler de plus en plus
de de ces longévités en équipe de France
parce que Ben en effet c'est quand même
ça veut dire aussi que peu de blessure
donc beaucoup d'emmagasinement
d'expérience maintenant ben voilà c'est
je fais un peu pareil avec Jean-Pierre
Papin qui qui a fait quelques clubs à
droite à gauche et qui qui a du mal à
percer tout simplement qui est qui est
vite redescendu dans les échelons et
c'est vrai que les gars et après il a
entraîné comme charte par exemple
exactement qui est c'est vrai que
grand joueur tous les grands joueurs ne
sont pas des grands entraîneurs voilà
parce que c'est vrai que
Papin c'était c'était quand même un très
grand buteur alors oui Chris je pense à
la rigueur on pourrait presque faire le
le le comparatif entre ces deux joueurs
c'est à peu près la même le même type
d'aura mais voilà la mayonnaise ne prend
pas ne prend pas toujours là on va pas
on va pas mettre trop de comment de
négatif puisque les résultats se passent
bien se passe bien à Versailles
pour le moment Djoko on va avoir ce que
ça va donner dans les dans les semaines
dans les semaines à venir est-ce qu'il
va rester est-ce qu'il veut partir en
Ligue 2 ce serait je pense
ce serait une grosse perte parce que
c'était un des acteurs de du beau
parcours en Coupe de France l'année
dernière donc voilà
on a alors on a l'impression moi depuis
depuis l'année dernière que Versailles
il y a tout le temps quelque chose qui
met une grande salle dans les dans les
rouages mais ça se passe toujours bien
il y a un lubrifiant qui suffit pour
pour faire en sorte on va peut-être voir
le classement ils sont deuxième pour
l'instant du classement journée donc on
a bien avancé dans le championnat 25
points pour Versailles Concarneau 29
points donc ils sont pas si mal à
Versailles
le maintien est assuré le matin est
presque assuré et donc enfin on se
souvient du parcours de l'année dernière
en Coupe de France où ça n'avait jamais
été facile
là c'est pareil il joue quand même il
joue toujours pas les matchs à domicile
ils sont pas vraiment à domicile on est
toujours au stade à Paris la jambe moins
voilà donc c'est vrai que il y a
toujours une histoire et puis finalement
ben ça continue n'oublie pas que
l'intersaison avait été aussi compliqué
il y a eu beaucoup de départ donc ben
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
finalement la la mariée ne continue pas
à rester belle et que l'histoire va bien
va bien continuer bien finir juste la
parole à Grégory après à vous pire
chevalier comme les camarades parce que
pour l'instant les résultats lui donnent
raison à Chris il est arrivé alors on
rappelle depuis le départ dufibi il y a
eu une première défaite du FC Versailles
juste après le départ du chef Chili
Chris n'était pas encore arrivé il y
avait un intérim qui s'était mis en
place au sein du club une défaite face
au Stade briochin qui était dernier on
pouvait s'inquiéter peut-être que ça
interromperait leur belle-série ils
étaient deuxième à ce moment-là et
finalement bah chris est arrivé il a
obtenu deux victoires et ce que c'est le
fruit du travail de Christ difficile à
dire il faudra attendre un petit peu
avant de se prononcer oui là là c'est
pas forcément
christologique et la qualité du groupe
qui est présente et qui travaille depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines
aujourd'hui le FC Versailles est
toujours deuxième ce qui me fait être
mitigé dans le sens on va dire négatif
c'est plus le manque d'expérience de
Chris quand on regarde son son palmarès
en tant que joueur il est il est très
doré vous l'avez rappelé mais en tant
qu'entraîneur pour le moment à part
avoir entraîné la réserve de l'Olympique
Lyonnais et l'équipe du Mans national
avec qui la collection est quand même
plusieurs revers et c'est aussi pour ça
que les dirigeants du Mans sont séparés
de Christ ils étaient 12e
début novembre à peu près
licencier par par le club de du Mans
donc peu d'expérience alors qu'on
attendait peut-être à ce niveau-là pour
un FC Versailles qui attire de plus en
plus de noms clinquants peut-être un
entraîneur avec de l'expérience
justement qui puisse aussi gérer les ego
qui vont commencer à grandir au sein du
vestiaire parce que les noms commencent
à s'accumuler pour le pour le FC
Versailles donc pour le moment j'attends
avant de me prononcer d'autant qu'en
plus dans les deux matchs remportés sous
la nouvelle air Chris il y a jérémyland
ce qui s'est aussi débloqué donc
peut-être que ça va aider aussi des
joueurs d'un avec qui un peu plus de
renommée à franchir un cap à aider un
peu plus Versailles Chris c'est quand
même pas un nom inconnu du monde du foot
et des passionnés du foot donc peut-être
que ça va aider vers ça il y a à grandir
peut-être que si la stratégie du FC
Versailles c'était de se dire on va
prendre un oncle clinquant qui parle
forcément aux passionné du foot comme ça
on va parler de Versailles on va attirer
encore la lumière des projecteurs sur
Versailles c'est peut-être aussi ça fait
partie aussi de la stratégie peut-être
des dirigeants Versailles
à Versailles oui mais espérons que ça
reste pas sur le clinquant et qui est
quand même une suite dans les dans les
résultats pour le moment tout est ouvert
à Versailles mais il faudrait pas que ça
vire au rouge très rapidement quoi pour
reprendre les propos de Yann sur le le
grain de sable dans les rouages c'est
vrai que nous au rugby on vois un de nos
grands frères parce qu'on n'est pas du
tout au même niveau vous le voyez oui
mais entre les pros les pros et les
amateurs on est à des niveaux différents
mais cette impression que cela donne
c'est que c'est une au départ une
trajectoire de comète avec avec ce
parcours en Coupe de France l'an dernier
et cette montée cette montée en fin de
saison et qui sont à la croisée des
chemins entre entre la sur la manière de
gérer justement cette cette exposition
exponentielle
est-ce que est-ce que ils vont continuer
à
avec prudence à construire et à se
structurer ou est-ce que justement ils
font des ils font des apports parce que
ils sont pris par le temps pour aller
pour aller monter en Ligue 2 et qu'il
faut des noms et qu'il faut attirer et
qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre justement
prendre des dispositions pour finalement
aller vite le seul risque a priori qui
qui guette c'est d'aller trop vite là si
on regarde dans le rétro ils sont ils
sont deuxième de national
l'objectif qui était inavoué au début de
saison de monter directement deux années
de suite il est il est palpable là
on disait en rigolant mais donc le
maintien est assuré c'est déjà c'est
déjà la base pour cette première saison
en National donc la suite c'est ce qu'on
entend ce qu'on entend dire est-ce qu'on
ce qu'on perçoit un petit peu c'est que
il y a il y a différents points de vue
qui s'opposent qui s'opposent encore ça
datait déjà du temps de du président
voisin
et là maintenant dans l'organisation des
des dirigeants
présidents directeurs généraux et le
sportif tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
en ce moment donc c'est en train ils
sont en train de faire leur mieux ou pas
de course souhaitons que ça continue ça
continue malgré tout à se faire à ne pas
se faire au détriment du sportif bon
pour l'instant c'est pas forcément le
cas mais les bouleversements ça va
forcément impacter l'équipe à un moment
ou un autre à votre avis et puis il y en
aura d'autres il y en aura d'autres
c'est sûr le billet vous pensez que les
bouleversements peuvent perturber
l'équipe il y a du Jarrier
après est-ce que les ça dépend si les
joueurs ont la capacité à rester juste
focus sur sur le le sportif
voilà c'est pourquoi un changement de
président un changement de trésorier ou
des guerres de machin etc vous êtes
obligé de les appeler souvent les
guerres de clocher voilà nous on est
foutu sur le sportif le reste c'est la
tambouille c'est la tambouille interne
du club
voilà nous on est là pour pour réussir à
avoir nos pour réussir à gagner des
matchs on prend les matchs par un et
voilà moi la seule chose qui qui
pourrait aujourd'hui faire un peu peur
justement si à cette
cette évolution en Ligue 2 c'est le
projet stade qui qui pour l'instant est
à zéro quoi
sur le voilà il y a pas il y a pas il y
a pas eu de et ça ça fait ça fait ça
fait peur et c'est ça peut être
problématique parce que ça plaît le
Paris Saint-Germain et s'entraîner au
Camp des Loges et jouer à Paris avec
peut-être une mauvaise surprise dans les
dans les semaines à venir
s'appelait le FC Versailles et jouer à
Paris bah c'est on n'est plus le FC
Versailles donc
voilà tout ça faut
voilà je ouais ça fait beaucoup de
dossiers à gérer et donc mais les
joueurs restent foutus sur le sportif
occupez-vous du terrain de gagner vos
matchs et le reste et le reste c'est pas
votre c'est pas votre problème mais ce
qui prouve aussi que peut-être le FC
Versailles va très vite et un peu en
train de changer aussi de dimension par
rapport à au championnat national dans
lequel le club évolue c'est qu'on voit
de plus en plus de noms alors on a il y
a duré Madeleine ce qui est arrivé qui a
un ancien international néerlandais qui
a quand même quatre matchs de Coupe du
monde à son actif donc ce n'est pas rien
et on voit le FC Versailles se mettre
sur des dossiers de joueurs peut-être
des pépites internationales qui
pourraient arriver au club en tout cas
il y a des rumeurs qui circulent la
dernière on a en rigolé avant l'émission
mais c'est ce Félix amados ce jeune
joueur uruguayen que serait en train de
négocier Versailles pour une arrivée
peut-être au mercato de janvier ça
prouve bien le changement de dimension
c'est à dire qu'avant Versailles allait
faire son mercato dans les clubs qui
étaient adversaires dans dans les poules
de National 2 dans les poules de
national là on va directement chercher à
l'international pour essayer de
d'étoffer son effectif donc qui suit par
beaucoup de clubs européens et des
joueurs voilà un joueur en l'occurrence
à Mado qui est suivi par plusieurs
plusieurs clubs européens donc ça montre
aussi que bah ils ont passé la vitesse
supérieure et ils ont changé aussi de
dimensionnel
est-ce que c'est trop petit est-ce que
c'est trop petit finalement mes
ambitions c'était la Ligue 2 de l'année
dernière déjà l'ambition c'est de venir
en Ligue 2 c'était pas de devenir en
Ligue 2
voilà les deux dans le futur puisque
l'objectif c'est de construire un
nouveau stade pour pouvoir accueillir
une équipe qui puisse évoluer c'était et
donc la construction du stade on donc
l'année dernière en étant 2021
construction d'un stade on s'est mis ça
se fait pas comme ça donc c'était oui
projets de Ligue 2 peut-être 2024 2025
voir après mais là oui il y a des choses
qui s'accélèrent et il faut peut-être
pas brûler toutes toutes les étapes mais
il y a peut-être une cellule de
recrutement qui qui est très efficace en
tout cas le prochain match de Versailles
c'est ce vendredi 9 décembre contre le
Red Star un très beau match en
perspective un véritable choc face au
troisième du classement on continue à
parler football dans l'envolée de
Grégory le moment le plus fort de cette
émission il nous a préparé du très lourd
aujourd'hui de quoi allez-vous nous
parler Grégory dans dossier qui fait
grand bruit Michael en ce moment avec
cette question sur toutes les lèvres le
Paris Saint-Germain va-t-il quitter son
ancre historique du Parc des Princes les
dirigeants du club de la capitale le 10
depuis plusieurs années leur enceinte de
48500 places n'est pas suffisante pour
arriver au top niveau financier sportif
le PSG donc engagé dans des négociations
pour acheter le site à la mairie de
Paris qui en est propriétaire pour
ensuite mener de larges travaux
d'agrandissement et monter la capacité à
au moins 60000 places problème la
municipalité demande minimum 350
millions d'euros somme démesurés pour le
propriétaire du club 14 portes
silvensment qui a de son côté proposé
aux environs de 40 millions d'euros à la
mairie de Paris le club a lancé un
ultimatum déguisé dans le journal
L'Équipe par la voix de du président en
Acer el releafi
s'ils ne veulent pas accepter notre
offre on part on menace pas on se serre
la main on remercie la mairie et on se
dit au revoir a-t-il déclaré
effectivement si les négociations
échouent l'équipe parisienne s'en ira
ailleurs alors parmi les pistes évoqués
il y a celle de racheter le Stade de
France de construire un stade flambant
neuf à Paris à Saint-Cloud ou même à
Poissy au sein du nouveau centre
d'entraînement que le PSG est en train
de construire alors ce n'est pas que
l'idée de voir le PSG jouer ses matchs à
Poissy me déplaise dans les Yvelines
mais pour moi le Parc des Princes est
indissociable de l'histoire du PSG
remontons un petit peu les années et
parlons de l'histoire du club qui a été
créé en 1970 on le rappelle c'est le
fruit de la fusion de deux clubs le
Paris FC le stade saint-germain-nois et
depuis 1974 c'est à dire quatre ans
après la création du club le PSG évolue
au Parc des Princes c'est l'entre
véritable du Paris Saint-Germain là où
il a réalisé ces plus grands exploits
quelques-uns on peut les citer la
victoire 24 ans qu'on le contre le Real
Madrid c'était en 1993 en quart de
finale de Coupe de l'UEFA cette victoire
aussi en quart de finale cette fois-ci
de la Ligue des Champions en 95 en 95
contre le FC Barcelone de crush on peut
citer aussi les nombreux classico on
parle ici de l'histoire du club des
moments moins aussi glorieux peut-être
mais il faut partir de l'ADN parisienne
ils sont ancrés durablement dans cette
ADN parisienne alors pour le collectif
ultra Paris la place du PSG d'ailleurs
c'est au parc ils l'ont affirmé dans un
communiqué qu'ils ont publié il y a
quelques jours nous n'avons pas vocation
à nous immiscer dans les discussions les
négociations et les rapports de force
entre le club et la mairie de Paris mais
nous savons une chose nous nous battrons
de toutes nos forces pour que le PSG
reste au parc à l'heure où le futur du
football s'écrit à coup de millions
d'euros voire de milliards d'euros je
pense que conserver quelques traditions
et plus que préférable il ne faut pas
tourner le dos à ces traditions encore
moins à son histoire et pour moi le
Paris Saint-Germain doit rester du
simplement et peut-être même
définitivement au Parc des Princes le
PSG doit-il rester au Parc des Princes
oui ou non vous votez
oui pour vous Pierre Chevalier pourquoi
d'habitude
pragmatique tout à fait pragmatique on
est on vient d'en parler pour le FC
Versailles qui qui délocalisait en
attendant mieux à jambon à Paris le PSG
même si ça s'appelle Saint-Germain c'est
Paris c'est Paris c'est Paris d'abord et
c'est pour ajouter à ce que à ce que
Greg présentait brillamment sur le sur
l'histoire du PSG c'est aussi cette
histoire avec les Parisiens et avec les
supporters qui habitent c'est en plein
en plein 16ème c'est un écrin alors
effectivement peut-être maintenant avec
le développement du club peut-être un
petit peu un petit peu restreint en
termes de en termes de place mais il y a
quand même déjà plus de 40 000 places
48000 places
et on ne sait absolument pas si si le
PSG partait au Stade de France ou à
Poissy si la migration se ferait déjà de
toutes les deux tous les groupes de
supporters actuels plus d'autres
spectateurs est-ce que est-ce que les
les spectateurs et les fans du psgraient
le déplacement régulièrement pour
remplir 60 000 places ou plus dans quand
on est à une demi-heure ou une heure de
Paris centre en transport en commun
voire éventuellement en voiture donc
purement pragmatique l'histoire comme le
comme le comme l'esprit et la culture du
PSG ce sont inscrits dans Paris doivent
le rester là c'est une querelle de
grosses ou sur de l'immobilier pur et
dur et puis de de d'un planning
stratégique et d'un plan financier de
part et d'autre pour que pour que tout
le monde en fait finalement que tout le
monde tire la couverture à lui
mérite Paris en tête mais là c'est il
s'agit il s'agit du club de sport de du
club de foot de la capitale de Paris
donc oui l'histoire qu'on doit continuer
à s'écrire au Parc des Princes
impossible peut-être vous voyez pas le
PSG à Poissy
ah bah si je parte à Poissy et si il
construisent un stade de 60 000 places
je pense qu'il a 88 places je pense
qu'ils ont du mal ils auront du mal à
remplir le stade en étant à quoi sinon
voilà ça c'est quand même une ça c'est
une des premières réalités
qui peuvent arriver des Yvelines par
exemple enfin le Parc des Princes c'est
quand même hyper accessible pour les
Yvelines c'est
118 à 13 vous y êtes tout de suite c'est
quand même très très facile plus dur
d'emmener les les supporters de l'autre
côté à votre avis je pense que oui c'est
plus difficile de de faire le de faire
le chemin inverse tout simplement parce
que quand vous venez de la province
Île-de-France vous arrivez facilement en
région parisienne par contre quand vous
êtes de la Province de France pour
pouvoir vous déplacer entre entre en
interconnexion ça devient très très vite
compliqué donc
donc voilà pourquoi ouais je pense que
on aurait ils auraient du mal à mettre
60 000 ou une personne sur sur Poissy
après la migration sur Saint-Denis ça
pourrait être une une idée mais dans ces
cas là on change complètement l'ADN et
enfin ouais l'ADN des supporters parce
que on est plus du tout sur la même sur
la même population tout simplement donc
entre la Seine-Saint-Denis et le 16e
c'est pas la même c'est pas la même
population donc là on change on change
beaucoup de choses dans l'ADN du club il
y aurait peut-être là la possibilité de
de d'avoir 100000 personnes mais les
prix des billets pourraient pas être les
mêmes donc est-ce que financièrement
c'est une c'est jouable je suis je suis
pas sûr je pense que
le gros Descartes est dans les mains de
la Mairie de Paris et de toute façon ils
ont ils ont eu entre deux chaises
c'est-à-dire soit
excusez-moi encore allez je prends soit
ils acceptent l'offre de vente du de à
Paris et le PSG reste ici s'occupe de
faire les travaux soit il refuse et dans
ces cas-là ils perdent leur locataire
[Musique]
contre offre à 10% à 10% de la valeur
moi j'ai l'impression alors c'est
peut-être du bluff effectivement mais
qu'on est face à une impasse parce qu'on
a un Paris Saint-Germain qui en plus a
annoncé qui voulait se désengager
légèrement du club qui ne serait pas
contre avant 5 à 10 % des parts du club
on voit mal le Paris-Saint-Germain
mettre 350 millions d'euros sur la table
pour acheter le Parc des Princes doctor
donc que dans leur calcul pourquoi il
propose 40 millions qui je pense qu'il y
a un juste milieu à trouver 40 millions
ça sent très minimum couteau c'est vrai
que la jambe de Neymar mais c'est vrai
que la mérite Paris à retorqué bah même
par aidé ça a coûté plus cher au Paris
Saint-Germain que le parquet Paris days
coûte plus cher que le Parisien
principal a écouté 50 millions 50
millions d'euros je pense qu'il y a un
juste milieu à trouver mais le PSG dans
son calcul inclut les 80 millions
d'euros qui ont déjà été dépensés par le
club pour une rénovation entre 2014 et
2016 c'est ça juste avant l'Euro 2016
pour agrandir légèrement et moderniser
le stade on est passé de 47000 à 48500
donc en termes de capacité
n'a pas gagné énormément mais on a
modernisé un peu le stade on a un petit
peu plus mis aussi d'air d'espaces VIP
parce que c'est aussi sur cette
clientèle là que mise beaucoup le le
Paris-Saint-Germain mais malheureusement
moi c'est un souhait que je mets sur la
table j'ai l'impression qu'on est quand
même sur la table qu'on est sur la table
qu'on est face à une impasse pardon et
partir au Stade de France serait pour
moi pas forcément une bonne solution
parce que le Stade de France n'est pas
pour moi un stade de football c'est une
Arena multisport on peut faire des
meetings d'athlétisme on peut le faire
on peut faire aussi des concerts mais le
Parc des Princes est vraiment un pur
stade de football comparé au Stade de
France on a des tribunes qui sont à
moins de 50 mètres à chaque fois des
différentes
et je trouve une manière générale depuis
l'arrivée depuis ici le PSG s'est
racheté une conduite c'est à dire que
c'est devenu maintenant les travées du
Parc des Princes sont on va dire ils ont
ils ont fait d'une certaine manière une
espèce de discrimination par les prix
des abonnements alors pas forcément des
des coques d'Auteuil ou de Boulogne mais
ils ont ils ont fait aussi une vaste pur
il y a un il y a un s’inscrit dans le
16e et dans Paris il y a je pense des
des prévisions financières qui a intègre
tout ça effectivement faire une contre
offre à un tout petit peu plus de 10% de
l'offre initiale c'est quand même c'est
quand même c'est quand même assez osé
effectivement donc c'est peut-être là où
ils ont la force ce qui leur manque
simplement et là ça c'est le c'est la
mairie de Paris qu'il a c'est le choix
dans la date dans la partie dans la
partie négociation et dans la partie
prévision justement de c'est quand
est-ce qu'on signe la Nasser a l'air de
dire en gros on serre la main si si
c'est pas accepté on s'en va gros coup
de pression peut-être
parce que je pense que là pour le coup
le le plan B de partir de Paris je pense
pas qu'ils aient toutes les toutes les
consonances et notamment tous les
budgets pour pouvoir le réaliser facile
de dire ça peut-être qu'ils sont en
train de dire on va partir si vous tenez
pas ce qu'on veut au final est-ce que
c'est pas une peut-être une excuse pour
partir non mais sur aussi couper la
boire en deux trouver juste prix en fait
le juste milieu
et mais par contre la problématique elle
est réelle c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
en effet pour accueillir des des très
beaux mode de Ligue des Champions le
Parc des Princes est trop petit ah oui
après ça en Angleterre font à peu près
cette taille-là oui mais par exemple en
Angleterre
à Manchester vous avez deux clubs à
Londres vous avez trois ou quatre clubs
c'est pas du tout la même chose là à
Paris il y a un seul club et du coup ça
a eu un effet un peu pervers sur le prix
des places puisqu'il y a eu moins de
place donc le prix
avec une plus grande capacité pourrait
aussi à mon sens peut-être peut-être
réduire un tout petit peu le prix des
billets qui commence à exploser et
aujourd'hui il faut une offre globale
de l'abordable au Premium en tout cas on
suivra ce dossier avec attention on va
maintenant parler parler encore une fois
football de la Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar cet événement vous le
savez était très décrié dans le monde il
y a eu la polémique écologique avec les
stats climatisés dans un pays où il fait
chaud il y a également les morts sur les
chantiers beaucoup de personnes ont
appelé au boycott de l'événement dans
les Yvelines on a eu du mal à trouver
des endroits qui diffusaient les matchs
le mardi 22 novembre nous étions du côté
de Bois-d'Arcy dans la salle La Fabrique
il y avait peu de monde devant la télé
mais la mairie a fait le pari de
retransmettre le match on écoute le
maire de la commune Jean-Philippe Luce
nous on veut juste passer un moment
festif évidemment tout ce qui s'est
passé au Qatar et les conditions de
l'attribution sont assez compliquées il
faut pas obéir les problématiques de
développement durable et de traitement
de tous ceux qui ont travaillé à la
construction de ces stades mais là on
est face à la compétition face au sport
et on a besoin de moments de
convivialité tous ensemble et je suis
content qu'il y a une grosse antenne de
personnes ce soir pour un premier match
en plein hiver
la mairie a retransmis les autres
rencontres dans les Yvelines Le
Perray-en-Yvelines a aussi retransmis
les matchs mais peu de communes ont
assumé d'organiser des événements autour
des Bleus est-ce que vous comprenez ce
tabou avant de passer à la question
générale ce que vous comprenez ce tabou
ou pas oui ou non Pierre Chevalier au
bout du raisonnement c'est à dire que
avant le début de la compétition il y
avait ces données politiques
sociologiques qui ont animé tous les
débats
il faut aller au bout c'est à dire que
les aides à chaque fois vont au bout de
leur raisonnement c'est à dire de ne pas
organiser de Fan Zone par exemple c'est
ce qui avait été déclaré à la mairie à
la mairie de Paris faut pas oublier non
plus que c'est une période totalement
inédite pour une pour une coupe du monde
on peut appeler en plein hiver donc
c'est la première histoire
à cette quand il fait 5 degrés 5 degrés
dehors maintenant quand on après on
viendra peut-être à la question d'après
mais c'est c'est là le Sport reprend ses
droits en fait c'est ni plus ni moins
c'est c'est cette nature humaine qui est
capable de faire abstraction aussi de
tout de tout ce qui s'est passé avant ça
a été exprimé ça a été exprimé en disant
le les 6000 morts sur les chantiers les
chantiers des stades au Qatar cette
cette aberration écologique de de
climatiser les stades en plein en plein
désert il arrosé et d'arroser les
pelouses bon ça a été dit ça a été
pointé ça a été non pas boycoté mais là
pas le décrit une fois décrié et une
fois que une fois que la compétition a
été lancée on retrouve cet élan
populaire que le sport est capable de
donner et que le football notamment est
capable de drainer on peut comprendre
qu'il y a eu un certain tabou pierre
parler des postures politiques les mères
sont avant tout des élus alors ils ont
pas tous des partis politiques mais
représente aussi des idéologies qui
peuvent porter à droite comme à gauche
etc et ils ont été plutôt fidèles aussi
à leur position ça c'est la posture
politique effectivement le Sport reprend
ses droits c'est pas aux supporters
c'est pas aux fans de football d'être
pris en otage pour des décisions qui ont
été prises il y a il y a une dizaine
d'années maintenant effectivement il
faut s'indigner il y a des données qui
ont été avancées par des journaux très
sérieux sur les 6500 morts sur sur les
chantiers sur l'aberration ici
écologique avec ce bilan carbone qui va
être juste explosé avec cette coupe du
monde il y a la construction des stades
climatisés mais aussi tous ces points
aériens qui sont organisés avec les pays
limitrophes du Qatar pour acheminer les
supporters sur sur les matchs le jour
tout ça il faut son indigner maintenant
le supporter de football a envie de
regarder son équipe l'équipe de France
peut-être brillée peut-être une autre
équipe aussi nombreux supporters
marocains qui s'émerveillent des
performances du Maroc dans les Yvelines
et c'est pas eux des prises en otage eux
ils sont fans de football c'est pas eux
d'avoir des postures forcément
politiques c'est plus aux politiques
justement qui ont pris les décisions
avant de prendre ce genre de décision et
monter d'un cran deux images prises
pendant le match de l'équipe de France
ce dimanche 4 décembre à 16h face à la
Pologne la première image dans un bar de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye un bar bondé pour
soutenir l'équipe de France et supporter
on fait beaucoup de bruit à chaque but
et l'ambiance était bonne enfin ils
étaient environ 150 dans l'établissement
et quelques autres en terrasses l'autre
photo a été prise après le match de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux en dernière le
district contre le FC Mantois les vices
chinois ont filé directement voir la
rencontre après le coup de sifflet final
aux alentours de 16h30 c'était
d'ailleurs le cas pour beaucoup de
joueurs des Yvelines tout sport
confondus les matchs le match étant
programmé pour la plupart aux alentours
de 15 heures total 14,32 millions de
Français ont regardé cette victoire de
la France face à la Pologne et son
peut-être beaucoup plus face à
l'Angleterre je vais juste passer un
petit peu de gueule en tant que joueur
amateur je trouve ça vraiment dommage
alors je sais qu'au niveau des
calendriers au niveau du choix dans la
date c'est difficile pour la FFF de
décaler les matchs je trouve quand même
dommage que les matchs amateurs soient
tenus quand même ce dimanche à 15h ce
qui a empêché beaucoup de football
amateurs dont je fais partie de regarder
la première mi-temps de l'équipe de
France on a loupé une bonne partie du
match de l'équipe de France et je trouve
ça dommageable
[Musique]
avoir des horaires traditionnels c'est
plutôt bien voir des matchs qui débutent
à 20h moi mes enfants ils sont super
contents de pouvoir au moins pouvoir
voir la première mi-temps et d'avoir des
modes qui finissent à 23h et qui est
d'ailleurs des fois il voit même pas le
début de la première mi-temps parce
qu'ils sont endormis avant quoi donc là
je trouve que 20h mine de rien c'est
c'est un très bon horaires pour pour
pouvoir faire pour mettre du foot et le
rendre accessible
à la famille tout simplement c'est le
message de capitaine du Jarrier j'espère
que vous serez entendu il y a du Jarrier
ça met du temps à démarrer c'est vrai
les matchs de poules alors qu'il y a eu
du jupette
et des grosses surprises ça mis beaucoup
de temps à démarrer là je crois que à
partir des 8e de finale on a on a on a
atteint le le degré de popularité lambda
d'une coupe du monde en plus là il y a
quand même justement la question sur
cette thématique est-ce qu'il y a moins
d'engouement dans les Yvelines est-ce
que vous le ressentez oui ou non
casting pour les raisons
que ce soit en hiver c'est je veux dire
il y a aussi un paramètre à prendre en
compte c'est la sobriété énergétique
est-ce que organiser des fan zone ou de
gros événements qui vont nécessiter
forcément beaucoup de dépenses
énergétiques à l'heure où on parle de
sobriété énergétique est-ce que ça
aurait été bien vu et bien perçu par par
les populations je n'en doute est-ce que
les gens me regardent pas plus
finalement devant leur télé c'est la
question
14 millions c'est à 14 millions sur le
dernier match c'est 14 millions c'est
14,32 millions sur le dernier match et
il y avait 12 millions de spectateurs
pour le premier match face à l'Australie
ce qui avait pas pendant les matchs de
poules je crois que c'est les soirées
spéciales les soirées entre amis et
soirée en famille vous regardez le
regarder le foot de chez soi et fait
évidemment et là là on voit on voit le
on voit la mutation pour les 8e pour les
carpes ça va monter en puissance surtout
s'il est cap du front l'équipe des
Français elle va loin parce que j'allais
parler des Marocains et avec cette cette
formidable fête hier soir comme s'ils
avaient gagné la Coupe du monde
les images du Maroc si on les a voilà
l'ambiance avec nos amis marocains
c'était je crois à Mantes-la-Jolie
Mantes-la-Jolie donc on peut voir les
Marocains fêter à la victoire c'était
plutôt bon enfant comme comme on peut le
voir fumigène drapeau et on a entendu
des klaxons toute la nuit dans les
Yvelines c'est c'est inédit pour le
Maroc hein c'est la première fois qu'ils
at ce stade de la compétition avec une
équipe très internationale il y a très
peu de joueurs formés au Maroc c'est
essentiellement des joueurs qui ont été
formés à l'étranger notamment en France
il y a quelques joueurs formés en France
effectivement France Espagne Belgique
même Pays-Bas ça fait plaisir de voir ce
genre d'ambiance et concernant l'équipe
de France je trouve pas qu'il y a une
tellement une grosse différence par
rapport aux autres années en 2018 même
si la France est championne du monde ça
va il y a pas eu d'engouement dès le
début ça a commencé à prendre à partir à
l'éducar de finale après l'Italie par
exemple Grégory ce qui est plus ambiance
en Italie en ce moment
en Italie non mais en Italie non il y a
les premiers matchs de l'Italie mais il
y a un rapport au football qui est
différent je pense qui est en France il
faut peut-être attendre les quarts de
finale demi-finale il y a vraiment le la
passion du monde se rapproche à ce qu'on
peut voir en Espagne en Amérique du Sud
ou le football est vraiment intégré dans
la société il se rapproche même d'une
religion presque pour pour certains fans
on a une perception différente mais
c'est vrai que l'engouement la monte
petit à petit mais je trouve pas que ce
soit bien différent la seule différence
c'est qu'on n'est pas en été et
qu'effectivement il y a pas les fan zone
comme on avait pu voir c'était à l'été
2018 c'est sympa par rapport à 2018
selon vous j'ai pas j'ai pas cette
impression là en tout cas on le voit sur
les audiences télévisées c'est pas
forcément c'est 40000 de téléspectateurs
en moi en Europe je parle bien en Europe
et en même temps Europe enfin il y a
quand même pas mal de pays qui sont
rentrés qui sont rentrés à la maison
aussi
c'est que c'est que là maintenant on a
maintenant qu'on est en car on a des
gros affiches donc là ça devrait
vraiment soutenir le la montée en
puissance de l'effet populaire Coupe du
monde parce qu'on a on a des gros matchs
en perspective là qui arrive ici à la
semaine il y en a pour le coup des
équipes qui restent après une phase de
poules complètement atypique là on a des
cartes d'écart de finale qui sont qui
sont a priori dans les plaques dans les
plaques à costaud et même là il y a
enfin
hormis le Maroc il y a zéro surprise les
7 autres
équipes qui qui sont présentes là vous
avez pas la Croatie qui est une très
bonne nation du football mais qui reste
quand même un petit pays vous avez que
des grosses grosses nations et l'Europe
et l'Europe est quand même dominatrice
encore une fois on va terminer sur cette
thématique par un pronostic c'est notre
rituel on va commencer par par vous il y
a du Jarrier on laisse
qui va gagner la coupe du monde
qu'est-ce que vous êtes vraiment besoin
que je réponde à cette question la
France la France évidemment je suis
tellement Chauvin que après on va voir
un très beau match un très beau France
Brésil en finale
mais moi après les 8e de finale
forcément moi je vais pas parler de la
France je veux porter malheur à personne
de finale l'équipe qui m'a quand même
moi le plus impressionné c'est le Brésil
ça fait très longtemps qu'on a pas vu
une équipe brésilienne aussi complète
que soit de la défense à la taxe sans
oublier le gardien aussi Alison le
gardien de Liverpool ça faisait très
longtemps une équipe aussi solide la
dernière fois je crois que c'était en
2002 et ils étaient ils étaient devenus
champions du monde à la fin donc c'est
vrai qu'on va voir on va voir ce qu'il
en est mais après tout le reste tout le
reste voilà c'est clair que la France
elle est elle est elle est largement
présente on va passer maintenant notre
page débat
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler de voile de
divin White est engagée sur la Route du
Rhum 2022 Laurent bolitain Louis Burton
sur Bureau Vallée et le versailler Eric
Bellion sur son bateau comme un seul
homme Powerade by Altavia et ça c'est
pas très bien passé pour les deux
divinants on va commencer par Louis
Burton le skipper à une nouvelle fois
dématé en début de course 3 jours après
le départ et il a perdu son mât alors
qu'il était dans le top 10 de la course
dans la catégorie IMOCA c'est la
deuxième fois en deux ans que ce
problème lui arrive après la Transat
Jacques Vabre il a enregistré cette
vidéo
il était prudent
voilà il reste plus que ça
dégouté c'est incroyable comment ça
charge
à plus tard
qu'est-ce que vous pensez l'abandon de
Louis Burton
on va rappeler quand même que c'est un
bateau qui a déjà fait le tour de le
Vendée Globe qui était très bien très
bon bateau qui est un très bon bateau
qui a très bien fini le Vendée Globe 3e
non pas 3e plus que c'était
plutôt bien placé un bateau de nouvelle
génération quand il est fait le Vendée
Globe normalement Louis Burton elle est
capacités dans son dans ces
infrastructures de pouvoir améliorer ce
bateau et là c'est le deuxième départ
sur une grosse sur une grosse épreuve
après la Transat Jacques Vabre et deux
fois la même problématique moi je veux
dire j'attendais j'attendais cette
troupe du rhum avec impatience et au
bout de trois jours pour moi c'était
fini quoi j'étais complètement
désintéressé du du de la de l'épreuve
parce qu'il visait la victoire
au moins le podium
oui alors au bout de trois jours quand
on en multicoque il y a une grosse
partie de la course qui est faite
à 6 jours
c'est c'est quand même c'est c'est quand
même impressionnant maintenant quand on
est au niveau cas en trois jours voilà
la course elle est loin d'être jouée
donc il était dans le et voilà les
distances étaient vraiment ridicule moi
j'avais commencé à suivre à prendre mes
habitudes de suivi le matin au réveil et
puis plusieurs jours
je suis tellement Chauvin voilà moi
quand je je suis libertone c'est vrai
que
je dors toujours bien il y a pas de
souci je me couche tard et je me lève
tôt mais c'est vrai que que ben ouais je
trouve que c'est inquiétant parce que
c'est la deuxième fois et c'est la
deuxième fois la même classe quoi donc
donc ça me ça me fait peur et puis et
puis ben mine de rien le enfin le Vendée
Globe va arriver très vite maintenant
inquiétant bah oui très inquiétant
forcément la même casse sur au même
endroit en un an en un an et demi
quasiment de de comment dire
d'intervalle c'est très inquiétant la
première fois sur la Transat Jacques
Vabre il avait mené l'enquête et il se
pourrait que ce soit une défaillance
quand même humaine peut-être pas la
bonne décision qui a été prise au bon
moment là en attendant savoir quand même
un peu plus sur sur cette casque est-ce
que au final c'est pas le bateau qui est
qui est défaillant c'est ça aussi qui
faut mettre en avant et je suis assez
d'accord avec Yann sur le fait que on a
perdu un peu de l'engouement en
rédaction alors on avait quand même un
deuxième yvelinois fort heureusement
engagé sur cette route du Rhum mais
Eric Bellion on aura pas les mêmes
objectifs mais Louis Burton qui est
quand même annoncé comme un grand favori
du prochain Vendée Globe en tout cas
c'est un statut que il a maintenant
légitime qui est légitime après ça sa
troisième place sur sur le sur le
dernier
on attendait on attendait quelque chose
de plus quelque chose supplémentaire il
avait franchi cette première nuit on
disait qu'il était tous les dangers
remonter de la Manche d'éviter peut-être
des objets non identifiés en mer on
parle souvent de d'OVNI mais il y a
aussi ses ovnis ok flottant non
identifié c'est d'éviter c'est d'éviter
tout ça il a évité ses premiers
problèmes des premières heures de course
mais malheureusement il y a il y a ce
mât qui qui sait qui s'est cassé donc
euh qu'on pourrait se dire c'est on
pourrait voir sur cette course c'est que
là ça a tenu deux jours de plus voilà
c'est ça problème de problèmes de
résilience dans dans l'équipe dans
l'équipe de Louis Burton et ce qui me
pose un problème lui casser le moral
aussi ce qui me pose un problème c'est
c'est justement c'est ce ce cette
acquisition d'expérience normalement on
en parlait techniquement avec avec les
par les techniques de des équipes
techniques pardon et lors de la lors de
la première casse de dire ils vont tout
faire pour mener une enquête et puis
pour pour trouver
la faille trouver la faille qu'elle soit
humaine humaine ou matérielle et
malheureusement alors il y a peut-être
un des effets subjectifs aussi avec la
chance la chance la chance qui ou la
malchance mais en tout cas ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que c'est qu'on arrive
pas à trouver
un la faille et à tirer à tirer profit
des expériences malheureuses de ces deux
dernières courses le jamais 203 peut
faire peut faire peur également dans
l'aspect totalement irrationnel donc
voilà c'est assez c'est un palpable et
c'est assez inquiétant pour un champion
de la trompe de loueur qui était bien
placé sur la course et alors dans des
conditions qui sont loin d'être des
conditions difficiles je veux dire là ce
que Louis nous montre
sa vidéo ça augmente voilà c'est c'est
normal de vivre ça
qui sont d'ailleurs moins 80% des
courses se déroulent dans ce dans ce
type de météo voir pire plutôt que le
grand beau temps quand il quand il
traverse quand il traverse le
tour du
fondateur ou justement on se retrouve
sur des sur des merdes et donc c'est
c'est voilà c'est c'est rarement comme
cela voilà donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je dis que c'est inquiétant
parce que Ben le creux ne tourne on va
maintenant parler d'Eric Bellion le
verset il était donc engagé sur cette
édition 2022 dans la catégorie Moka sur
son bateau comme un seul homme powerad
by Altavia le navigateur de 46 ans a
terminé à la 23e place du classement il
visait un top 15 à la fin de la course
afin de se préparer pour le prochain
Vendée Globe pareil est-ce que c'est
décevant pour
Eric Bellion ou finalement on attendait
peut-être un petit peu moins d'Éric
Bellion que de Louis Burton
il est terminé il a rallié il a rallié
la Guadeloupe et
et son matériel son matériel est tenu
donc oui on a déjà on en avait moins
parlé on avait moins parlé on avait
moins Paris sur la performance attendue
que celle de que celle de rumeurton bon
voilà c'est c'est pas si loin de
l'objectif initial c'est rapidement il
nous reste 8 minutes d'accord Louis
Burton c'est on est là pour viser le
classement
Bellion on est là pour aller chercher le
finisher c'est pas du tout le même le
même c'est quand même le top 15 là
top 15 vous mettez pas la pression au
moment du départ alors oui il y a plus
de monde et je pense que ce qu'on a vu
sur sur la route sur cette route du Rhum
va se reproduire aussi sur sur le Vendée
Globe il va y avoir beaucoup plus de
bateaux au départ
le petit motif de déception oui c'est
qui réussit pas son objectif mais on est
quand même loin de la déception qui nous
a animé juste après l'abandon de Louis
Burton
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de peler le roi du football qui
a emporté trois Coupes du Monde plus
difficile et la victoire plus grande et
la joie de gagner je vous laisse méditer
sur cette phrase à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]